je suis dans la merde qu'est-ce qu'il y
a
dans la merde pourquoi j'ai fait un
appel d'urgence sans faire exprès ça
fait 9 8 7 depuis tout à l'heure
je pense que toute ma famille va penser
que je suis en train de décéder
à quelle famille de fruits le citron
appartient-il à grume bonne réponse
d'après le titre d'une série de Molière
comment il imagine bonne réponse
mardi les tensions échauffent les
naufragés de Koh-Lanta on l'a vu dans ce
reportage les camions adorent sont très
fiers de ces matatou non seulement ils
nous entend plus Nicolas je crois qu'on
va le récupérer est-ce qu'ils nous
entend
c'est bon ça y est Nicolas si vous nous
entendez est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter l'importance de ces matou pour
l'identité même du pays
on a perdu Nicolas
par les militants de la CGT
[Applaudissements]
Sophie Binet 41 ans et devenu ce matin
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT
à l'issue d'un congrès tumultueux
congrès qui jusqu'au bout à ressembler à
une soirée en disco night Thomas Kumba
tout le monde a bien déjeuné
on n'est pas là pour s'amuser il y a
encore du boulot cet après-midi mes amis
et puis la CGT mes camarades bien
entendu j'ai ici le sac tout de suite de
Gisèle vidalena si jamais elle cherche
son sac il est à la tribune contre toute
attente c'est Sophie Binet qui succède
donc à Philippe Martinez
la personne qui pouvait donc rassembler
donc la direction
issue de la branche ingénieur cadre et
technicien elle devient la première
femme à la tête de ce syndicat depuis sa
création en 1895 c'est un symbole pour
toutes les femmes du pays pour toutes
les travailleuses pour toutes les
syndiqués c'est un message vraiment fort
alors ça n'arrive pas souvent quand on
parle de match entre l'Allemagne et la
France surtout qui a l'Argentine dans
X-Men mais bon bref mais en matière de
grève nous battons nos voisins il faut
bien le dire ainsi selon une étude de la
Fondation allemande Hans Blokker publié
en 2020 ont comptabiliserait 114 jours
de grève par an pour 1000 salariés en
France contre 18 en Allemagne
pas de trêve il y aura pas de suspension
il y aura pas de médiation on gagne le
retrait de la réforme des retraites
[Applaudissements]
Emmanuel Macron dans Pif le mag Olivier
du subtil et bientôt Marlène Schiappa en
une de Playboy une communication
politique pour le moins oser que ces
Parisiens ont un peu de mal à décrypter
est-ce qu'elle va faire d'un playboy
franchement les ministres doivent être à
leur tâche plutôt que d'être dans des
lieux du divertissement Emmanuel Macron
j'aurais envie de lui poser deux
questions aussi ils viennent donner une
question légère ils viennent donner une
interview un journal pour enfants je lui
demanderai faire le trésor ou puis il y
a jet ah c'est pas gentil ça
c'est quand même un petit clin d'oeil au
boxeur en fait
je suis issu d'une grande famille j'ai
quatre grands frères et quatre grandes
soeurs et du coup mes parents se sont
dit on n'a pas de Mohamed on a pas d'Ali
et ben on va l'appeler Mohamed Ali c'est
drôle comme c'est un étudiant étranger
ça devrait être un des derniers à parler
aujourd'hui dans un pays tellement
aujourd'hui
alors
Jean Messia vous étiez vous étiez vénère
je suis vénère parce que je ne supporte
pas qu'on dise du mal de la France et
surtout pas quand on est étranger Marine
Le Pen
Marine Le Pen c'est
oh là là
Marine Le Pen c'est quand vous parlez
pas vous montez donc vous avez pas peur
un jour d'avoir une idée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du bonheur pour toi il a osé rappeler
que la France est un État colonial et
raciste et pour ça il s'est pris toutes
les offensives réac et facho de la terre
entière la vérité c'est qu'en fait ils
ont la rage quand un arabe ou un noir
prend la parole et pas de politique la
vérité c'est qu'ils ont le seuil quand
les quartiers populaires sont organisent
pas de politique bon en manifestation
donc pour tout ça en fait on lui envoie
toute la solidarité et on arrêtera
jamais face au facho à poser moi je suis
à l'arabe qui prend la parole je me suis
pas énervé vis-à-vis de moi-même
Eric Zemmour
je l'ai vu chez vous il y a quelques
semaines sur la mission oui il y a deux
semaines et j'ai remarqué qu'il avait un
amour immodéré de lui-même et donc je
voudrais savoir si son amour immodéré de
lui-même est inversement proportionnelle
à ses succès électoraux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Éric la blanche quelle est la différence
entre un con et un connard on fait
relativement simple le connard il est
méchant le con il est bête
va complètement avec la spiritualité
parce que pour moi la spiritualité c'est
intégrer Socrate tout ce que je sais
c'est que je ne sais pas ça le fait
cette phrase c'est très beau on la
valide je suis un peu folle de continuer
de penser pour y arriver rendre le soir
des animaux heureux de ramener à la
maison rendre des enfants heureux
des humains heureux on a fait le boulot
c'est peut-être le seul sens de notre
humanité
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
S